the ladies they love my hair damn small
we couldn't stop on the street or like
on a train I was like it's like own
attack chiller and I'm just like I had a
few missed appointments and it just kept
going huh and this happened and you've
been blowing it off for a year and and
this is where we get ya you don't shower
in the morning right actually washed my
hair like two to three times a week
takes about 40 minutes writing like
detangle in Washington comb I realized
that if I don't keep my hair moisturize
it will like break off I like this one
cause it's actually very light so it
works really well for my hair I go to a
lot of hair products - yes it's a lot of
hair to move the wire so it's definitely
two more yeah put it back of my head I
just kind of do like just a crazy like
swipe it up in place yeah I can you
spray on this was on a miracle milk it's
kind of like my leave-in conditioner
just kind of spray it all over and then
give it like one quick wipe down
sometimes I do use this all this is made
by dark and lovely I don't like using it
that much because I feel like it gets
all over the place just one just one
this is something that you put on like
right after you get out the shower feel
frightened get dressed
you will probably yeah yeah so you don't
drip this on your shirt in light back on
the towel so once you're well
moisturized what do you do what are the
finishing touches before you walk out
the door I do this uh-huh the top of my
hair things always fall for that so I'm
always doing this you want the full arc
I need to form yeah I just got to make
sure like the sides alright and in the
back of it tends get flat to equal my
back I'm gonna try the rustle and pop it
doesn't really wear it out it works so
thanks Reggie one of the all-time great
efforts thanks for taking us through it
happening yeah alright guys that's it if
you got any style questions for GQ leave
them in the comments and I'll see you
next time